[Music]
this is the Chinese mega city of
Shenzhen a gleaming monument to China's
economic miracle in 1980 it was a town
with around 60,000 residents now it's
China's technological hub with a
population of over 12 million
[Music]
entrepreneurs high-flying tech graduate
and international companies flock here
to join the tech revolution
welcome to Shin Jae
[Music]
chené gents it's north of Hong Kong in
the Pearl River Delta one of the most
densely organized regions in the world
the area has an estimated population of
120 million people in 1980 Shenzhen was
dedicated a free economic zone an
experiment in market capitalism in
communist China the effects were
explosive shen gens populations
skyrocketed in just over 30 years the
city has a massive migrant work force
over 4 million residents stay during the
week and then return home on the weekend
but it's tech hardware that's put this
city on the map if Silicon Valley dreams
it up then this is where it's made this
is a while Chung Bay Market arguably the
world's largest electronics market
filming here is banned but here's a
sneaky peek the markets neon-lit
corridors stretch across multiple
buildings and many floors the stalls
sell everything from the latest gadgets
to the tiniest screws and many items of
ripoffs Chinese fakes of us products but
if you wanted to you could buy all you
need to build your own smartphone or
100,000 of them
[Music]
because Schengen draws in workers from
across China its food scene is just as
varied as its population if you're
looking for the full banquet experience
Shang palace and the shangri-la Hotel
has got you covered there dim sum lunch
is a feast for the eyes and the mouth
it's a showcase of authentic Cantonese
cuisine or try something a little more
casual such as Chinese hot pot a
simmering pot of soup stock is kept on
your table and you put your choice of
ingredients in one of the most famous
variations is flavored with Sichuan
pepper so watch out it packs a serious
spicy punch
when you get the bill you'll notice QR
codes here in Schengen they're used by
locals to pay for just about everything
simply scan the code and the money's
transferred sounds great but there's a
hitch you can't use them unless you have
a Chinese bank account so a technology
to make life easier
only works if your local finally why not
enjoy some sport Shenzhen style
this is Robo master a competition put on
by local drone and tech company DJI
student teams from around the world
compete using a variety of self-made
robots to shoot each other and destroy
the opposition base the competition aims
to foster engineering and programming
and keep shen gen at the forefront of
the tech revolution
[Music]